[Music]
in what could be the most exciting thing
to come out of the Mandalorians since
baby Yoda is news that rosario Dawson is
joining the cast for season two as
ahsoka tano so let's talk about how this
formerly animated iconic female Star
Wars character will tie into the
Mandalorian on this episode of the
ketchup work-from-home edition I haven't
moved from this chair in days okay so if
you don't know who is so Gaetano is
you're a loser just kidding
so ahsoka tano was first introduced in
the 2008 Clone Wars animated film and
remained a key character in both the
Clone Wars and later the Star Wars
rebels animated series and she'd been
voiced by ashley eckstein up until this
point I am thank you ahsoka was first
known as the bratty Padawan to Anakin
Skywalker before he becomes Darth Vader
spoiler ha
kidding again okay so throughout the
season she learned about the force and
the nature of war and those experiences
caused her to eventually leave the Jedi
Order Sarila in Star Wars rebels which
was set a number of years after the
Clone Wars in just a few years before a
new hope we got to see a more mature
ahsoka who is now assisting the emerging
Rebel Alliance in the rebels season 3
finale her story led to a fateful fight
with our boy Vader and her survival
remained a mystery until the closing
moments of the series only learned that
she did indeed live into the post
Empire era so as rosario Dawson
reportedly takes over the character the
ex Jedi ahsoka will likely be droppin
some vast galaxy knowledge on the table
like where the child comes from seeing
as she knew Yoda and what the F the
force is seeing as everyone from season
1 had no idea
and her parents may very well have
something to do with the dark saber
which popped up throughout the animated
series and most recently the season
finale of the Mandalorian maybe she'll
train mando to use it while guess taw
knows appearance could also open the
door for other rebels characters to show
up as well and that includes Sabine a
female Mandalorian who teamed up with
ahsoka for new mission as rebels came to
an end in roughly the same time period
as a Mandalorian but since one of the
key creative voices on the Disney Plus
series is Dave Bologna who also
co-created Clone Wars the possibility of
more characters and storylines crossing
over from the animated show seems likely
right someone tagged dave down in the
comment is about to change
speaking of felonio depa sewed he will
be back directing along with other big
names like show creator jon favreau show
star carl weathers and the newly
announced robert rodriguez who will be
doing at least one episode and I'll just
sit here secretly hoping that Z client
will come back from the dead and by the
way Rodriguez previously worked with
rosario honest in city movies but it's
unclear of his episode or episodes will
involve ahsoka but hey it would make
sense woman my Valkyrie and as of now
season 2 is still set to debut in
October with most of the shooting
already reportedly finished so if
post-production can be done on a
work-from-home basis and October could
still happen guys
looking forward to that and driving
again alright friends it's time to kick
it over to you guys now are you excited
for live action ahsoka and what other
animated characters would you like to
see crossover into the show let us know
in the comments section also for more
streaming news and a galaxy's worth of
binge guides head on over to Rotten
Tomatoes calm also don't forget to join
our ketchup fan group on Facebook so you
can connect with other fans of the show
and talk about what you're currently
streaming like Zack here who is caught
up on multiple classics as always thank
you guys for watching to catch up I'm
Matt Perez and I have eaten all my
quarantine snacks
[Music]